welcome back to the David Pakman show.
Okay.
Yet as it sometimes happens on the show, we
will have problems with last minute guests,
cancellations and today was one of those days.
So in order to not delay production of the
show, which would be hugely disrespectful
to our audience, we're going to take a few
phone calls.
There were a lot of people who want to get
on today and see what is on people's minds.
Of course the phone number is always (617)
830-4750.
Let's go first to our caller from the five
to zero area code five two zero.
What's your name and where are you calling
from today?
Hey, what's up David?
Uh, this is Justin calling from Albuquerque.
Hey Justin, what's going on?
Hey, uh, I was just wondering your opinion
on, uh, people who become sort of apolitical
for one reason or another.
Um, like I've met quite a few people who like
sort of fell for the Donald Trump, uh, rhetoric
and they just like the side that politics
is evil in general.
Hmm.
So do you think that it would be worth trying
to talk those people back into politics?
Well, so when you say that it fell for the,
for Trump, did they vote for Trump and then
after voting for him, say they're no longer
engaging in public politics?
What do you mean?
Yeah, I mean in, uh, I mean anecdotally, but
in several cases of people I've met, they
voted for Trump or they just decided that
Trump and Hillary were equivalent.
Um, and I could see how they came to that
conclusion cause when I was younger I could
maybe fall for that kind of mindset.
Um, but I was just wondering if you thought
it would be worth trying to talk them into
politics or if they would maybe fall for the
same sort of rhetoric.
Well, here's the thing, here's what I think
is important to explain to those folks in
the same way that not voting is not a neutral
act.
When you don't vote, that is a proactive decision
you make not to participate.
And it does tend to help Republicans.
So if you're saying, I'm just not going to
vote and I'm, I'm staying out of it, you're
actually typically helping the more conservative
candidate in most places who often is a Republican
and in primaries you end up helping often
the most extreme republican in the same way
you can opt out of participating in the electoral
process.
You can't really opt out of politics.
I mean, if you don't live in the middle of
nowhere, uh, in, in a completely, you know,
disconnected way in some kind of state of
nature in rural northern Alaska or something
like that.
And even then, this may not even apply.
You are subject to what is going on politically.
If you're in touch with the financial system,
if you have a job, if you earn money, if you
have a house, whatever you are involved in
politics, you might be choosing not to participate
ELAC.
Totally.
But I think the point I would make to people
when they say I'm just not involved in politics
is you're involved in politics.
You're just choosing not to try to influence
what that looks like.
But either way you're involved in effected
by it.
That that's the reality.
You can't really not be.
Yeah, I mean that's, that's a great point.
But um, like you think that people kind of
avoid politics for like emotional reasons
or,
sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, listen, it's exhausting.
It's exhausting and particularly now it's
extremely depressing and you know from the
time I'm done with the Friday show until the
weekend ends and I'd start preparing the Monday
show, I pay attention to no news and politics
and its particular, yeah,
I understand Stan,
the instinct, I just think it all ultimately
comes down to you're effected by, by politics,
no matter whether you participate, not, and
it's a question of do you want to have a say
or don't you?
But either way you are going to suffer from
the repercussions of the decisions made by
those who are participating.
And if I could quickly ask a follow up, like
if someone, if you get the sense that someone
is avoiding politics for those emotional reasons,
do you think that it would be bad to try to
talk them into this?
Because from my perspective, things have just
gotten so intense that like, it's like you
said, you just, you have to be involved.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I would be empathetic.
I would say empathy.
I would be empathetic.
I would say I understand that.
What I would encourage them to consider is
that the short term increased involvement,
if we all did it might give a significant
longer term, uh, circumstance significantly
better, longer term sort of circumstances
during which we can focus on other areas of
our lives without having to be so worried
about what it is that's going on in Washington.
That that's the argument I would make.
Justin, thank you.
I really appreciate the call.
I've got a bunch of people holding, so I'm
going to let you go, but I do hope to hear
from you again.